So the first thing we're going to do to implement our hash
table index, is we have to figure out how to create an
empty hash table. With a simple index, this is really easy. To
make an empty index, we just have an empty list, there are
no elements. So we can initialize the index by just initializing
it to an empty list. And as we added elements to the
list, we would just add them to the empty list. For the
hash table that's not going to work. We need to do something
more complicated to start with an empty hash table. And the reason
for that is we need to start with all the buckets. So
our initial value, for the plain index, was just an empty list.
Our initial value for a hash table needs to be a set
of empty buckets. And the reason for that is, we want to be
able to do lookups right away, and we want to be able
to add elements to our hash table. If we just started with
an empty list, well then, the first time we look up a keyword,
it would say, that keyword belongs in bucket 27. We don't
have a bucket for that. We would need to figure out how
to create that bucket. It makes a lot more sense to
start by making our empty hashtable be a, list of buckets. Where,
initially, all the buckets are empty, they're ready, waiting for keywords
to be placed in them. So what we need is code to
create that empty hash table. So, I think you know enough to
define make_hashtable yourself, so we'll make that a quiz. So your goal
is to define a procedure, we'll call it make_hashtable,
that takes as input a number, giving the number of
buckets in the hash table. And it outputs an
empty hash table that has that number of empty buckets.